in the last video we described what is
the deep l-larry neural network and also
talked about the notation we use to
describe such networks in this video you
see how you can perform fold propagation
in a deep network as usual let's first
go over what forward propagation will
look like for a single training example
X and then later on we'll talk about the
vectorized version where you want to
carry out forward propagation on the
entire training set at the same time but
um given a single training example X
here's how you compute the activations
of the first layer so for this first
layer you compute v1 equals W 1 times X
plus b1 so W 1 and B 1 that parameters
that affect the activations in layer 1
right where this is layer 1 of the
neural network and then you compute the
activations for that layer to be equal
to G of Z 1 and the deactivation
function G depends on what layer you're
at and maybe index AB has the activation
function from layer 1 so if you do that
you've now computed the activations from
there 1
how about layer to say that there well
you would then compute v2 equals W to a
1 plus B 2 and then so the observation
of layer 2 is the way matrix times the
outputs of layer 1 so that value plus
the bias vector for layer 2 and then a2
equals the activation function apply to
z2 ok so that's it for layer 2 and so on
and so forth until you get to the output
layer that's layer 4 where you would
have that V 4 is equal to the parameters
for that layer times the activations
from the previous layer
Plus that bias vector and then similarly
a four equals G of v4 and so that's how
you you know compute your estimated
output Y hat so just one thing to notice
X here is also equal to a zero because
the input feature vector X is also the
activations of layer 0 so we scratch out
X I'm going to cross out X and put a 0
here then you know all of these
equations basically look the same right
the general rule is that ZL is equal to
WL times a of L minus 1 plus B L 1 there
and then the activations for that layer
is the activation function applied to
the values Z so that's the general for
propagation equation so we've done all
this for a single training example how
about for doing it in a vectorized way
for the whole training set at the same
time the equations look quite similar as
before for the first layer you would
have Capital Z 1 equals W 1 times
capital X plus B 1 and then a 1 equals G
of Z 1 right and bear in mind that X is
equal to a 0 these are just Neil the
training examples stacked in different
columns you could take this let me
scratch out X we can put a 0 there and
then for the next layer a little similar
Z 2 equals W 2 A 1 plus B 2 and a 2
equals G of Z 2 right we just take
these vector Z or a and so on and
stacking them up so this is V vector for
the first training example V vector for
the second training example and so on
down to the M training example and
stacking these and columns and calling
this capital V alright and similarly for
capital A just as capital X all the
training examples are column vectors
snacks left to right and then they then
end of this process you end up with y
hat which is equal to G of Z 400 this is
also equal to a 4 and that's the
predictions on all the new training
examples of stand horizontally so just
to summarize our notation I'm going to
modify this up here our notation allows
us to replace lowercase Z and a with the
uppercase counterparts it already looks
like a capital D and that gives you the
vectorized version of forward
propagation that you carry out on the
entire training set at a time where a 0
is X now if you look at this
implementation of vectorization it looks
like that there is going to be a for
loop here where it says left for l
equals 1 to 4 for l equals 1 through
capital l then you have to compute the
activations for layer 1 and the layer 2
then for layer 3 and they're gentle
therefore so since that there is a for
loop here and I know that when
implementing your networks we usually
want to get rid of explicit for loops
but this is one place where I don't
think there's any way to implement this
other than explicit for loop so we're
implementing for propagation it is
perfectly okay to have a for loop that
compute the activations for layer 1 then
there are 2 then they are threes and
therefore no one knows and I don't think
there is this any way to do this without
a for loop that goes from 1 to capital L
from 1 through the total number of
layers and in your network so this place
is perfectly okay to have an explicit
folder so
that's it for the notation for deep
neural networks as well as how to do
forward propagation in these networks if
the pieces we've seen so far looks a
little bit familiar to you that's
because what we're seeing is taking a
piece very similar to what you see in in
the neural network with a single hidden
layer and just repeating that more times
now it turns out that we implemented
deep neural network one of the ways to
increase your odds of having a bug-free
implementation is to think very
systematic and carefully about the
matrix dimensions you're working work so
when I'm trying to develop my own code
I'll often pull a piece of paper and
just think carefully through so the
dimensions of the matrix I'm working
with let's see how you could do that in
the next video